3 marseille 13 normal c'est la zone
c'est marseille qui voit mais toujours
faire le signe c'est comme ça qu'on m'a
appris
[Musique]
ici c'est chez moi ça où j'ai grandi
et puis j'ai 4 ans pas tout est symbole
de marseille allait marquer nos kalakan
shaker normale et le joker c'est mon
surnom joker et la nd et avec mon 3 13
marseille j'ai vécu toute ma vie ici et
là de rentrer à la maison un peu je
retrouve mes potes d'enfance et ma
famille tu vois je les vois pas souvent
et du coup ça fait plaisir de manger
chez mamie papilles se gaver de bonne ou
bonne marseille c'est là où j'ai grandi
et où j'ai fait mes premières connerie
mais premier et mes premières amitiés
tout toi c'est là que je kiffe ses
meilleurs dans le monde pour moi tu
connais par carte hd connaît comme si
c'était justement dans la mer où il est
celle bella non ils en pensent quoi le
papa de le voir revenir à marseille a
bien chaud au coeur franchement non
c'est bien dit content est-ce que vous
rêvez la première fois où il a émis soit
1,7
oui oui c'était sur la route des crêtes
alors du côté de cassis j'avais pris un
skate d'adultes et j'avais découpé à sa
taille et sa muse a poussé à monter
dessus s'amuse à salonique
[Musique]
premières olympiades fantastique n'ont
jamais pensé qu'ils puissent le jour
qu'ils puissent aller aux jo super pour
lui quoi et alors si j'ai bien compris
si jamais tu as remporté une médaille
tant mènera marchais sur le podium c'est
ça j'amènerai mars et sur le podium
d'après je ramènerai le bol de marseille
chez moi mon âme entre dans mon jardin
je vous le dis moi
[Musique]
sinon tu frères mes épaules jeremic
ni blanche ni mois minimum de tina c'est
mon petit but vide
[Musique]
si j'aime bien mais c'est
les membres du giaba grandi ici comme un
inconnu ici c'est que c'est là il est là
aussi si tu fasses elle est ce que je
pourrais gagner m'a rendu fou 6 pendant
des années on était petit mais je m'en
veux tellement j'étais de combat de
lutte
on passe toute notre vie ici en fait
quand on a fini ce qu'a dit on vient ici
et et on reste déjà parlé à faire
n'importe quoi
[Musique]